la mort a probablement été causé par la
fracture de la colonne
on se souvient tous des publicités chocs
mais cette fois c'est la loi que le
gouvernement du québec voudrait changer
resserrer le code de la route
en s'inspirant du modèle de l'ontario on
a voulu vérifier qu est-ce que
l'expérience l'ontario a donné
[Musique]
oh
le bilan routier des jeunes conducteurs
québécois s'améliore mais encore un
accident grave sur cinq et impliquant un
conducteur de moins de 24 depuis plus de
20 ans l'ontario interdit aux débutantes
conduire la nuit et pour les moins de 21
ans
pas une goutte d'alcool n'est permise
les résultats de l'expérience
ontariennes sont éloquents dès
l'adoption des mesures le nombre
d'accidents chez les jeunes a chuté de
plus de 30%
même chose en nouvelle écosse qui a
adopté également ce genre de règlement
maintenant que le québec songe également
suivre le modèle ontarien québec
voudrait aussi tripler les amendes pour
ceux qui textes au volant des
contraventions qui pourrait atteindre
600 $ chapitre l'ontario songe aller
encore plus loin avec des amendes
atteignant 3000 $ des suspentes pendant
un mois le permis d'hériter du vistre si
on veut aller aussi loin c'est que
l'ontario estime qu'une personne est
blessée toutes les 30 minutes par un
automobiliste distrait
quand on roule à 100 km regardez son
téléphone ne serait ce que 5 secondes
ça équivaut traverser un terrain de
football les deux yeux fermés vous
voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
voici l'adresse